-Welcome back to "The Tonight Show," everybody.
It is time to play a game that tests
just how connected two people are to each other.
It's time to play "Jinx"!
-♪ J-J-J-Jinx, J-J-J-Jinx ♪
-Our first team tonight, they're the Emmy-nominated founders
of Magnolia Network who've released
seven "New York Times" best-selling books.
It is Chip and Joanna Gaines!
Come on!
-What?! What?!
-Yes. Welcome! Welcome, welcome!
Their opponents, they're the hosts
of the popular YouTube series "Good Mythical Morning,"
which is in its 23rd season.
Give it up for Rhett and Link, ladies and gentlemen!
-Ohh. -Wow.
Wow. -Boo!
-No, they can hear you. -Boo!
-Your microphone is on. Your mic --
-Boo! -The rules are very simple.
-That's not a good look. That's not a good look.
-I will give you a category.
I don't even know why we mic'ed you.
-Boo! -Stop.
-I'm gonna give you a category, then you both count to "three"
and name something in that category at the same time.
If you match, that's a jinx and you get a point.
If you don't, the other team gets a chance to steal.
Both teams, please put on your jinx gloves.
-Okay. -Right.
-This will help link your minds together.
-Oh. -We got it.
-You got it. -We got it.
-Yeah, so the gloves are connected.
If you try to pull away... you can't.
No. You are connected. -I think we're doing...
-Alright, once linked, feel free
to rest your arms on the provided elbow duvet.
-Oh. -Oh, thank you for that.
-This makes it easier.
-I'm starting to shake a little. -Yeah, I don't want --
This is not an endurance game.
This is more of a fun mental challenge.
Chip and Joanna, you are up first.
Can I have the category, please?
-Oh, my gosh. That's amazing!
[ Laughter ]
-Right from the bank vault. -Your category --
Whew. Your category is...
power tools.
-Oh. -Okay.
-Chip and Joanna -- I mean, this is --
-Alright. -You should know.
-Okay. -Come on. We got this.
-You got to say the same one.
Chip and Joanna, whenever you're ready.
-Got it. -One...
-You got it. -...two, three.
-Drill! -Drill!
[ Bell dinging ] -Yes, you both said "drill."
-What did you say? -Drill!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You said it. That's it. That's it.
Drill. That is a jinx.
You get a point and a lot of confetti.
Rhett and Link, you get to start this round.
Here we go. Let's get your category, please.
[ Air rushes ]
[ Laughter ]
Ready? Category is... ice cream flavors.
-Okay. -Ice cream flavors.
You're -- You want the jinx.
You guys are -- You're in the vibe.
I can see you guys looking into each other's souls.
-Oh, my gosh. -Look at -- Look at this.
This is intense. -They're better than I thought.
-Alright. Three, two, one.
-Rainbow sherbet. -Chocolate-chip cookie dough.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Rainbow sherbet. -I couldn't -- Rainbow sherbet.
-Come on, man. Everybody knows rainbow sherbet
is the first thing you think of. -That's true.
-Chocolate-chip cookie dough is pretty good, too.
Alright. Wow. You have a chance to steal.
-Oh, we got this. We got this.
-You got this? -This is easy.
-Easy? Ooh, alright. Here we go.
One, two, three.
-Vanilla! -Vanilla!
-What?! [ Bell dinging ]
-Let's go. Let's go. -You love vanilla?
That's your thing? -That's our spot.
-No, but I thought that's what he would pick.
-You knew that that's what he would pick.
-Well, it's peanut-butter chocolate, but it's so long,
so I just went straight for vanilla.
-I'm chocolate-chip cookie dough.
-Rainbow sherbet. Okay. Here we go.
Chip and Joanna, you're in the lead.
You're kind of crushing right now, 2-zip.
It is time for the next round. Can I get the category, please?
[ Air rushes ]
[ Laughter ]
Words that start with "M."
-Ohh! -One, two, three.
-Magnolia! -Mom!
-Oh...
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Ohh! Your own company! -Dadgumit!
-You're all about the -- Well, you're all about the cash.
Come on. Mom! Of course. -I'm a mom, you know.
-Every time we say "Magnolia,"
they give us a $100 cashier's check.
-You can't -- So, you can't say "Mom" or "magnolia."
-Dadgumit. -But you have a chance to steal.
Word that starts with an "M." Get in there.
Oh, my gosh. I can feel it! One, two, three.
-Muskrat! -Mammal!
[ Buzzer ] -Oh! A muskrat is a mammal!
-No, no, no, no. -A muskrat is a mammal!
-No, I understand, but no. -Give us half a point!
-They nurse their young!
-Alright. Words that start with "M."
-Okay. Great. -One, two, three.
-Mammogram. -Money.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-No. -Hey.
-Ahh. Unfortunately... -Yeah, yeah.
-That's what I was thinking, Chip.
[ Rasta horn blares ] -Ohh!
-You know what that sound means? -What?
-It means it's time for the final round.
The first -- [ Laughter ]
The first team to jinx gets 10 points
and will be declared "Jinx" champions.
-Oh! Oh! -Alright.
-So it's anybody's game. -It's anyone's game.
But, Chip and Joanna, you're up first.
-Let's go. -You get one chance to jinx.
Otherwise, Rhett and Link can steal and take the whole game.
-And we will.
-Can we have the category, please?
[ Air rushes ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell ding ]
-Well done. Well done.
-For 10 points.
-Whew. Come on, babe.
-Valentine's Day gifts.
[ Audience oohs ]
Valentine's Day gifts.
-Okay. -One, two, three.
-Jewelry. -Vacuum.
[ Buzzer, sad tuba plays ]
-You -- They win it. You deserve to win.
-Alright. So, wait. -They don't even need to do it.
-They want us to win so bad. -Jewelry or a vacuum.
-He said a vacuum.
-A vacuum. You could never give that.
That is the worst Valentine's Day gift
in your entire lifetime.
You guys got this. For the win. -We got it.
-Valentine's Day gift. One, two, three.
-Pony! -Pony!
-What?!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Yes!
-No way! -Oh, my God.
-Well done.
-Congratulations, Rhett and Link!
You have found the perfect link.
And the fact you had it on Valentine's Day, of course,
it makes it much sweeter. Congratulations.
Thanks to Chip and Joanna Gaines.
Rhett and Link!
We're talking to Chip and Joanna after the break.
Stick around, everybody. Come on back.